hello hello
so good to see you good to see you again
Christina Mandrell made her Bachelor
debut on Monday night but turns out
she's no stranger to the spotlight
[Music]
[Applause]
yep that's Christina in Taylor Swift's
music video for her 2008 single 15. I
love it
some eagle-eyed fans and likely die hard
swifties were quick to make the
connection during the premiere episode
of the ABC dating show after the content
creator introduced herself to Zach
shalcross you look amazing
in the music video Christina makes a
brief appearance locking eyes with the
Grammy winner
[Applause]
words
seriously Taylor's fans should work for
the FBI yeah I'm not gonna not gonna
seem ambivalent about that at all
Christina who is also Mom to a
six-year-old daughter Blakely caught
wind of all the chatter online and
addressed her Cameo on Instagram sharing
this clip from the show and joking in
the caption apparently I look at Zach
the same way I look at Taylor Swift I'm
really happy about that adding new
conspiracy theory first I stared at
Taylor then stared at Zach which
inevitably leads to me crying on the
stairs that last bit referencing footage
from The Season's super teas showing a
contestant lying on a set of stairs
sobbing inconsolably
but Christina's Showbiz ties go deeper
than Taylor my mom was part of the group
Barbara Mandrell and Mandrell Sisters if
I have to sing like I will but it is not
my passion by any means and things are
already heating up between Christina and
Zach during night one the two shared a
steamy kiss
foreign
[Music]
and you're just laying your heart out on
the line it's painful at times for sure
and you know it's so painful to have to
kiss all these women too you know you
just that's what you're signing up for
it's what you got to do so tough enough
yeah Zach actually kissed a lot of the
women night one
[Music]
but he tells E.T it's all in the name of
finding love for night one I made sure
to not like have you know for myself
like any rules or any like specific way
to do this like I didn't look to any
anyone else to try to navigate the right
way I just went in fully experiencing it
and like feeling and meeting all the
women I could like that was my first
priority though was just meeting as many
women as possible now the the kissing
you know the heart wants what the heart
wants and if the connection's there
absolutely I love that you wasted no
time I mean even at the limo entrance
with Bailey like you just went for it
gotta do what you got to do you gotta do
what you gotta do
[Music]